what is happening there reject nation we
are gonna watch today
from the man the greatest man to have
ever graced youtube
ryan george his pitch meeting for the
falcon
and the winter soldier can't wait to see
the things he points out that we agree
with or flew over our heads it's part of
the joy of the pitch meetings and is
always
always always so damn funny let's just
hop
into it
so you have a new marvel show for me yes
sir i do it's gonna be called the falcon
and the winter soldier
okay okay what characters is it gonna
follow the falcon and the winter soldier
that explains the title great work so
far yeah and so sam is struggling with
the fact that steve rogers left him the
shield right so he gives it to a museum
oh okay and bucky's dealing with some
government-mandated therapy and hanging
out with his buddy this really
old guy yori nakajima oh that's cute
whose son he murdered
oh my god yeah well he did it while he
was brainwashed and he's kind of
building up the courage to tell yuri
about it as part of his recovery so he's
like trying to get over having been the
winter soldier
exactly and so then the government names
this guy john walker is the new captain
america
oh i hate this guy already he doesn't
seem like such a bad guy
oh but he's such a bad guy okay but he's
not that bad eventually kind of
but not great oh i don't know how to
feel about this guy but i'm captivated
it's the perfect
well they want the world to go back to
the way it was before everyone was
snapped back because everything's all
messed up now messed up how well this
organization called the global
repatriation council are trying to get
things back the way they were before the
blip because now people are living in
each other's houses there are refugees
it's a mess
so what's their plan oh well about 20 of
them have taken super soldier serum and
their plan is to get out there and you
ju
go get you know go get go get it done
you're gonna head out there go
get it get it all taken care of i don't
get it
listen sir they have a vague plan
probably i'm gonna need you to get all
the way off my back about what
fair enough exactly to get off of that
thing anyway so their leaders the
surprisingly
young lady carly morgenthau and she
wears a mask and she's like mean but you
kind of get where she's coming from it's
just that her methods are questionable
oh sounds a lot like that emphasis nest
character from solo a star wars story oh
yeah i guess it does
make sure to make it different enough
okay good who should we get the player
what about that
next actress star wars story oh yeah
she's great good call
great so what's her deal why does
everybody look up to her because she
keeps saying things like our movement is
strong
okay all right is she like super
charismatic
or something no she just quietly says
fake [ __ ] and everyone's really into
that apparently well okay then so what
else is going on
we're gonna tackle some really important
topics like racism in america
oh we are yeah we're gonna have this
whole storyline with this old
african-american super soldier
isaiah bradley that the government did
tests on really heavy stuff
well yeah important stuff to tackle for
sure yeah also baron zemo's gonna do a
little dance
balance out some of the heavier stuff
with some lighter stuff so baron demo is
going to hit the dance floor okay what's
zemo doing in the show anyway well bucky
and sam realize they need his help so
they break him out of jail and he's much
sassier now oh yeah
because they want to find out where the
super soldier serum is being made right
and while they're there they're going to
meet sharon
carter she's from the movie she is and
there's this
my favorite delivery called the power
broker and we don't know who it is is it
mephisto
what no sorry i'm still a little riled
up from the one division pitch no this
power broker person seems to be a very
influential person in madrid
they're pulling a bunch of strings they
have crazy access to stuff
okay anyway so sharon carter seems to be
a pretty influential person
so sharon is the power broker what no i
feel like with the clues you've laid out
though it's not
nobody knows who the power broker is
like it's pretty obviously her though
also zemo's gonna put on his purple mask
from the comics oh why does he put that
on because it's gonna look good in the
tree
yeah it really does more carrying than
wearing
straight up calls sam's sister and
threatens his nephews so she's like
full-on evil
actually we're gonna act like she's
misunderstood i don't know seems pretty
intense yeah we're gonna act like she's
misunderstood you say so so eventually
her and the flag smashers are gonna
fight
against walker and his partner lamar and
we're gonna see that walker's taking
some super soldier serum oh he has
yeah and one of carly's people is
holding walker because their plan is to
stab him to death because he's a symbol
but then carly accidentally kills lamar
oh no
then walker runs over to lamar and the
flag smashers they all run away well why
don't they finish the job and kill
walker like they were trying to do
because this part of the scene is over
so they scatter
gets all mad and he kills that guy that
was holding him so carly can stab his
heart
very charitable it's not actually
because the bad guy was down and a bunch
of people were watching right yeah no
killing is bad but bucky and sam have
killed bad guys too right oh no they do
for sure but this guy was down and he
was like please don't kill me so it's
different
maybe some of the people bucky and sam
killed would have said that too
quickly because they died because they
died
that's why i love this guy that's such a
good point
i bet that's going to come into play
later yeah no not really though it gets
smashed immediately when he starts
fighting
vibration i guess that makes sense it's
just kind of a metal circle really but
we're going to hype it up in a
post-credits scene
sure why not so sam is going to exactly
freak out the real [ __ ]
you know how to lodge it into things how
to make it bounce and come back
yeah how does the shield work exactly
well it works who cares
[Laughter]
so anyway by the finale the flag
smashers are gonna have a pretty clear
objective oh they are yeah they're gonna
kidnap a bunch of grc
senators so they can't pass a
resettlement vote and so carly sets a
truck of hostages on fire
okay so we're done trying to paint her
in a sympathetic light right no we're
still trying
she's okay and get this we're gonna find
out that sharon is the power broker
right yeah i figured that out no you
didn't who else would it this is a big
twist though
okay so then sam is gonna show up and he
has this new captain america flight
booyah great that looks yeah he's great
he's fully protected
except the comic panel brought to life
oh protecting everything except your
brain cage is tight and so sam's gonna
have to save a helicopter full of
hostages oh man it's gonna be tough for
him to take out the pilot and make sure
the chopper doesn't crash
actually it's going to be super easy
barely an inconvenience
oh really it turns out one of the
kidnapped senators on board that very
helicopter knows how to fly the
helicopter so she takes over oh hey yeah
that worked out great
it sure did and so eventually carly's
going to be trying really hard to kill
sam because she's a sympathetic
character
it's very sad and then sam's going to
carry her body because it's definitely a
sad moment and then he's going to talk
to some
senators oh he is yeah he's going to be
like stop calling the flag smashers
terrorists
well i mean they literally used violence
and intimidation against civilians in
pursuit of political aims which is
you know the definition of terrorism
sam's gonna tell them to not say that
and then he's gonna keep
lecturing them for four to five minutes
okay and one of the senators gonna be
like okay but logistically what are we
supposed to do here and sam's gonna be
like do
better senator oh you know that does
sound like it's gonna help a lot it is
wow wow wow and so then sam's gonna make
sure that isaiah's story gets told nice
and then bucky's gonna go talk to yuri
and tell him what he did to his son oh
it's gonna be nice to see how that plays
out and we cut away
oh yeah we get out of there fast kind of
wish you let that moment break
nope i'm already gone before we even get
to see the moment i've been building up
to all season
okay and then during the end credits
we're gonna have the title card say
captain america and the winter soldier
so that's gonna be a nice moment for sam
you know
hasn't bucky's whole arc been about not
being the winter soldier anymore uh yeah
i guess i could have changed
dancing thing that seems like a weird
thing to include well i keep seeing this
gif of thanos twerking online so i feel
like the internet's really gonna like it
okay i mean we can include a second of
it and if people want more we could
release that online
oh yeah hey everybody ryan broke the
internet
video and if you liked it feel free to
click the like button and the subscribe
button and all
you know buttons of that nature there
are also like hundreds of other episodes
on the channel that you can check out if
you want also leave a comment down below
letting me know what other movies you
want to see pictures for and check back
soon for a new one because there's going
to be
new ones you know okay mortal kombat one
oh it's coming
where is that one where get over here
get on it with your immortal combat
pitch
yeah it's fun watching these because you
know like we talked for like 40 minutes
after our reaction was done
and then there's always something he
points out they're like well put
efficiently said and way to shine a
light on some things that we did not
discuss at all
but yeah you know like i i i one of my
issues with
when the season was done was like i love
the actress who plays carly
but i do feel there was some misguided
direction in how they captured the flag
smashers
and carly being the leader like i love
the reoccurring joke he has here
about she's a sympathetic character he's
gonna try to kill
sam cause she's a sympathetic character
and you're like no
by the end of this season she's pretty
much full on villain
yet they take a very sympathetic
approach to her but it seems to kind of
contradict some stuff and i feel like
some of the debate of the gray area
kind of gets lost in some muddy
territory with her character
it does and i feel like ryan george
officially
pointed that out really well yeah he's
really good at summing up
like both perhaps like the ironic intent
and also just how it turned out as
opposed to you know what the intent
would have been yeah and yeah i mean
with carly it makes me wish that you
know there's all that talk about like oh
they'd remove stuff from the flag
smasher plot but it makes me wish they'd
maybe gone back and shot
a couple other things to yeah flesh that
out
that is a great point about the zemo
mask it doesn't come back around with
an explanation like it's a cool
character like oh the zebo mask
maybe for like the comic readers it's a
deeper meaning
for them but as far as establishing it
in the show it doesn't do it it's a cool
looking moment and it's cool
visually to see but at the same time
we're like why does he just go and put
it on and it just takes it off right
after
like i grabbed it just to keep it on
hand just in case i get an opportunity
to really throw down with these guys
i think it is funny i mean we talked
about in our breakdown too about with
the post-credits scene of
the penultimate episode with john walker
building the shield how it's building up
like
big baddie john walker he's coming into
full fruition now
and then you know like his shield just
gets messed up within like a minute of
fighting and it doesn't really mount any
has a flip of character pretty soon
after that yeah
well i mean even his his reaction really
sells that too because even he's like
oh damn i'm not sure what i expected out
of that
i just love how they made like a post
credit scene out of that and then it
doesn't really amount to anything that
big and yeah that's what i thought was
humorous about it
and uh of course you know that is a
solid solid point of what he brought out
with bucky
of him not wanting to be the winner
soldier that's a big part of his arc
because yeah we touched on how like with
yuri and i think it's like a common
complaint that a lot of people have had
is how
the first episode of this season really
sets up having this big character moment
and then you kind of just brush past it
really fast in the final moments
but that's something i didn't even think
about was it was so exciting
to just see it be called captain america
and the winter soldier
like it was such an exciting time that
you don't even think about oh wait a
minute bucky
wants to move past this whole winter
soldier thing yeah and there's even that
powerful
it's subtle i don't know if it's
powerful but it's really subtle how
imagine poor they call him winter
soldier
and then someone addresses him as
sergeant barnes yeah
uh in the last episode so i mean would
it be a cool
captain america sergeant barnes well i
mean
as it ended some of the social media
chatter i saw was people
wishing they had gone with uh captain
america and the white wolf because
there's also
that mess yeah and with the involvement
of the dora melange and the touching
upon
of that name that moniker from them for
through io and stuff like it seems like
that would have made a lot of sense and
now the only thing i wonder is
maybe that'll be the arc of season two
we'll finally get another title change
by the end and they have a captain
america four in there as well
pretty soon we'll just get a bucky
central focus it's his it's him his is
the main character
anyway yeah as always never fails
never fails this man never fails he's
the king subscribe
to screen rant just so you can get
notified when pitch meetings are up
subscribe to the real rejects click that
notification bell hit that like button
check out our falcon winter soldier
reactions we'll see you guys soon